Daenerys Targaryen has been on quite a journey
throughout Game of Thrones, and it's anyone's
guess where she winds up at the end of Season
8.
Some of those guesses, though, sound more
plausible than others.
Here's a look at some Daenerys fan theories
that just might come true.
"I'ma show you something real special.
The script of the final season of Game of
Thrones, mmm!"
Perhaps the most complex theory about Daenerys
is that she will not only die, but will actually
become a White Walker - and it will be Jon
Snow that kills her.
This theory hinges on the legend of the ancient
warrior Azor Ahai, who has been prophesied
to return one day to save the world.
In author George R.R. Martin's Song of Fire
and Ice book series, which the show is based
on, it's said that Azor Ahai forged his famous
flaming sword Lightbringer by plunging it
into the heart of his beloved wife, Nissa
Nissa.
Some fans think that Jon is Azor Ahai reborn,
and that to reforge Lightbringer, he will
need to kill Dany.
"in the ancient books it's written that a
warrior will draw a burning sword from the
fire.
And that sword shall be Lightbringer!"
Making this theory even more complicated is
the idea that Dany will then rise as a White
Walker, just as her dragon previously rose
from the dead.
This is based on another ancient legend from
the book about a long ago Commander of the
Night's Watch who married a "corpse bride."
Some fans think that these two legends are
actually one and the same, and that Nissa
Nissa was the corpse bride.
So if Jon is Azor Ahai reborn, weilding a
sword of fire, and Daenerys is Nissa Nissa
reborn, reigning as a White Walker, the two
together will make up the "song of ice and
fire" that gives the book series its title.
Hey, we told you it was complex!
Speaking of prophecies from the book, there's
another one that didn't make it into the show
but still could prove crucial.
At one point, Daenerys is told she will be
betrayed three times - once for gold, once
for blood, and once for love.
Two of these have already happened in the
show: Ser Jorah Mormont betrayed her to King
Robert for gold, while the witch Mirri Maz
Duur betrayed her for blood.
So some fans theorize that it will be Tyrion
who betrays her for love.
Some say for love of his family, others suggest
for his own unrequited love of Daenerys.
Say it ain't so, Tyrion!
So, back to that whole Azor Ahai thing.
Many characters in the series believe Azor
Ahai is the subject of another prophecy called
"the prince that was promised," which foretells
the rebirth of an ancient hero who will save
the world.
Melisandre, the Red Preistess, is a big fan
of assuming any random schmoe is the Prince
that was Promised, first declaring it to be
Stannis, and later assuming it's actually
Jon Snow.
But one theory originally espoused in the
books by the Night's Watch Maester Aemon Targaryen
is the idea that Daenerys is actually the
prophesied hero.
It turns out the original prophecy was in
the ancient language High Valyrian, which
is genderless - meaning it could actually
refer to a princess just as easily as a prince.
One of the most explosive revelations of Thrones'
seventh season was the reveal that Jon Snow's
name isn't Jon Snow at all it's Aegon Targaryen,
and he's not Ned Stark's lowborn bastard,
but a member of the most royal family in all
of Westeros.
Born to Ned's sister Lyanna Stark, the man
audiences know as Jon Snow is the son of Rhaegar
Targaryen, making him the rightful heir to
the Iron Throne and Daenerys' nephew.
"Jon isn't really my father's son.
He's the son of Rhaegar Targaryen and my aunt,
Lyanna Stark."
Some fans expect this to be a major point
of contention, even leading to Jon and Daenerys
battling each other for the Iron Throne.
Let's hope it doesn't come to that!
Ever since audiences met Daenerys Targaryen,
they've been prepared to accept her as one
of the show's heroes.
But what if she's actually the ultimate villain?
There's precedent, of course, as the whole
reason her family was deposed in the first
place is because the Mad King Aerys went on
a literal reign of terror, burning people
alive at the slightest whim - just as Dany
began doing in Season 7.
In particular, the Mad King threatened to
destroy all of King's Landing.
That's something Daenerys seems poised to
do before the series end, though she won't
need wildfire to do it.
A confrontation with arch-enemy Cersei Lannister,
who currently sits on the Iron Throne, seems
inevitable.
And since leaked set photos seem to show King's
Landing in a state of destruction, it looks
as though Dany and her dragons may finally
finish what the Mad King promised.
Whether or not she completes her heel turn
in the process to become a true despot remains
to be seen.
Daenerys's journey began with a political
marriage, and some fans theorize her journey
will end the same way.
In order to solidify her claim to the Iron
Throne, a political marriage to Jon snow - or
even Jaime Lannister! - makes some sense.
Still, some sentimental fans theorize that
Dany will actually marry Ser Jorah... before
he's forced to kill her, and then die himself
trying to stop the Night King.
Okay, maybe they aren't so sentimental.
This is just one of several fan theories that
also believe Daenerys will become pregnant
with Jon's child, and that the series will
end with their offspring set to inherit the
Iron Throne.
Hey, at least somebody in that scenario would
have a happy ending...
...unlike our final fan theory, which suggests
that Dany might actually die at the beginning
of the season and will never even have a chance
to do any of that stuff.
Eagle-eyed fans compiling reports from the
various filming locations around the globe
reported that while nearly every single other
character of note appeared for filming, Emilia
Clarke, who plays Daenerys, did not, leading
some to conclude that her character must die
early, before those locations come into play.
Hey, you know what they say:
"Valor morghulis."
"Valor marghuils."
"Yes, all men must die.
But we are not men."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.